get big fast the mantra of amazon.com
and its boisterous founder Jeff Bezos
from the moment I got there the feeling
was that you just press down on the
accelerator harder and harder the
audacious entrepreneur rewrote the rules
of retail there really was this sense of
urgency around this internet land grab
that was taking place you know how do we
establish the Amazon brand and his
strategy didn't always pay off even
after Amazon went public people looked
at the financials and said this
company's not gonna make it amazon.com
was actually profitable in December 1995
must have been for about one hour with a
series of sly moves Jeff Bezos built and
rebuilt amazon.com if you ask a question
that Jeff doesn't feel like is something
they want to go into the answer he gets
gonna be the laughs and he's laughing
all the way to the bank
you can buy anything at amazon.com from
books music shoes and clothing to a
battle tank or a tiki hut Amazon is the
most successful online retailer in the
world and still run by the man who
created it back in 1994 Jeff Bezos Jeff
seemed to realize that being the
singular place where a consumer can find
and buy virtually anything that's
available in the retail market was a
critical part of the company's growth
strategy the public image of Jeff Bezos
is of a superhero entrepreneur and he is
that if you look at his life from the
very beginning he's taken risks and he
solved problems and he's created
billions of dollars well Bezos is more
guarded than his outgoing public persona
and declined to participate in this
program
Jeffery Preston Bezos was born in
Albuquerque New Mexico on January 12th
1964 to Jacquie guys a 17 year old high
school student guys divorced his
biological father and married Miguel
Bezos a Cuban immigrant and petroleum
engineer for Exxon Miguel adopted
four-year-old Bezos in 1968 Bezos
described his early computer experience
in a 2001 interview with the Academy of
achievement there was a company in
Houston that had loaned excess mainframe
computer time to this little elementary
school none of the teachers knew how to
operate this computer nobody did but
there was a stack of manuals and me and
a couple of other kids stayed after
class and learned how to program this
thing as a teen Bezos embarked on his
first serious entrepreneurial effort a
summer camp based out of his house with
an emphasis on science and literature
five students signed up at a hundred and
fifty dollars a pop in 1986 he graduated
from Princeton University summa [ __ ]
laude with degrees in electrical
engineering and computer science Nicolas
Carlson is deputy editor at Business
Insider comm and has covered Amazon for
six years
faizal's actually recruited into a hedge
fund and de shah and he didn't want to
work in finance he actually wanted to
work in computer programming but de Shah
is a computer programmer and the hedge
fund has sort of built around algorithms
and the type of technology that basis is
interested in it wasn't the only thing
he found interesting he came upon a
statistic that just astounded him he saw
that the internet was growing it two
thousand three hundred percent per year
and he just became obsessed with this
number
studying the top 20 mail-order
businesses Bezos saw an opportunity
online Chris Anderson is editor-in-chief
for Wired magazine you can see that
there was this technological tsunami
that was arriving that was going to
disintermediate was going to create new
distribution channels reset economics
change the way we bought and sold and
the question was which domain shall we
apply it to the answer was books a
commodity for which no comprehensive
catalog existed in July 1994 he quit his
secure Wall Street job to pursue his
dream to create one of the world's first
online bookstores his first investors
his parents who he talked about with the
Academy of achievement my dad's first
question was what's the Internet okay so
this he wasn't making a bet on this
company or this concept he was making a
bet on his son
in the summer of 1994 Jeff Bezos and his
wife Mackenzie headed to Washington
State
armed with $300,000 from his parents
entrepreneur and technology expert
Esther Dyson is chairman of the
investment firm adventurer holdings you
now have a lot of people leaving Wall
Street to go I'm trying to startups but
Jeff was different he had a really solid
business / Wall Street background and
then he created something amazing Bezos
and his wife settled in Bellevue
Washington and hired two programmers to
write the code Bezos related the story
in a speech at Lake Forest College in
1998 found a house that could serve as
the first business and had a garage and
seemed the right thing to do since
there's a history of startups and
garages this wasn't fully legitimate
because it was a converted enclosed
garage but I considered it somewhat
legitimate because it wasn't insulated
those were not impressive offices he
dubbed the company Amazon after the
seemingly endless South American River
with its countless tributaries on July
16 1995 amazon.com opened its virtual
doors to the public James Marcus was
employee number 55
Marcus was hired to write book reviews
for the site that was nothing more than
a list of titles when I checked out
their site to see if this was a place
where I might want to work I discovered
it was quite rudimentary actually there
was a front page with an eclectic
mixture of books but the most notable
thing was that there was a huge
catalogue of probably several hundred
thousand books at the time but there was
no content in that catalog the fledgling
amazon.com had no advertising budget
initial sales were generated solely by
word-of-mouth
Heath Terry is managing director of
internet research at Connor core Genuity
there was a lot different about Amazon
really from the beginning you know they
weren't in Silicon Valley they were in
Seattle they weren't really into the
whole hype of the bubble they were
putting out press releases every single
day the site caught on within a month
books had been sold to customers in all
50 states and 45 other countries
what was different than Amazon was that
Jeff ran it right he was organized he
understood distribution he understood
how to motivate people to buy he just he
did things with great attention to
detail
Bezos goal for growing the company could
be summed up in a simple line get big
fast was both a mantra and very much a
strategic decision on Jeff's part
everything had to be on steroids all
growth had to be on steroids Eric best
was manager of business development at
Amazon from 1999 to 2001 there really
was this sense of urgency around
capturing e-commerce market share this
internet land grab that was taking place
you know how do we establish the Amazon
brand and grow the overall business at
the expense of competitors and within a
very time-bound window the strategy paid
off big time by the end of 1996 the
company reached fifteen point seven
million dollars in sales the gains were
boosted by Amazon's ability to offer
tax-free shopping to most online
consumers what makes us different is
vast selection convenience we deliver
right to the desktop and also the fact
that we're the broadest discounters in
the world we discount over 300 thousand
titles basically the best-selling titles
that's twice as many titles as the
largest physical book store even offers
but early investors were frustrated the
surge in sales came without profits
while Amazon spent millions developing
software and expanding its business you
know there was a lot of a risk that was
taken on by the company during those
early days and I think there was a lot
of speculation around whether or not
that was the right thing to do it's easy
now to look back and say of course
Amazon needed that capital and they
needed to invest at the rate that they
did in order to achieve the scale that
they now have that was not always clear
from day one
what was clear was that Bezos was
unstoppable he kept up the pace and
powered ahead for Amazon's IPO the idea
was that you could not rest on your
laurels for one moment and that you just
had to keep innovating all the time and
staying out of the competition all the
time and never have even a millisecond
of complacency on May 15 1997 the stock
began trading on the Nasdaq stock market
at $29.25 a share nearly $12 higher than
its offering price the day of the actual
IPO was a very big deal there were you
know parties all over the company and
Jeff addressed us you know over the
speakerphone from New York I mean Jeff
was telling us on the phone you know
we've made history today you have all
made history today it was pretty damn
exciting but despite the well-received
IPO tech analysts still offered a dour
assessment of the company Tim O'Reilly
is founder and CEO of O'Reilly Media
most people remember the business story
that Amazon was going to be toast
people were scrutinizing their
financials they were saying this company
will never be profitable or there were a
lot of naysayers the company's engineers
were hard at work updating the site
introducing features like one-click
shopping by the end of 1997 the value of
Amazon stock nearly tripled Jeff would
say to us do not pay attention to the
stock price he was very confident that
in the long run it would go up and up
and up but felt it was very dangerous to
look at it in the short run
Amazon continued their frantic expansion
hiring more than 7,000 employees and
beefing up their product line you know
we just heard talk about virtually
everything in anything we could sell
groceries health care cell phone plans
and cell phones magazines and then
eventually you know hardware garden
hoses and toys the expanded product line
and high volume sales paid off for both
amazon.com and Bezos
on December 20th 1999 he was anointed
Time magazine's Person of the Year
made my mom cry and you know parents are
always proud and that feels great it was
the the ultimate legitimization of his
sort of starry-eyed dream of conquering
the world through e-commerce like you
flipped to the inside of the magazine
there's Jeff dressed as Indiana Jones
swinging on a vine it was kind of making
him into an American folk hero in a way
it's like you suddenly like Paul Bunyan
was in the office down the hall from you
Bezos was at the top of his game but an
industry-wide disaster was right around
the corner by the late 90s amazon.com
was an online juggernaut but in 2000 the
dot-com bubble burst stock prices
slumped and Jeff Bezos was forced to
take drastic measures there were at
least two waves of layoffs and as is
usually the case with these things you
don't know who's gonna go kind of cower
in your office and wait for the HR
person to you know summon you of the
finger and it feels bad to see your
colleagues go in the context of the
slowing economy and the the the deep
slowing and consumer confidence this was
the only prudent decision that we could
make by September 2001 the company's
stock hit an all-time low and bottomed
out at five dollars and 97 cents a share
from poster child to whipping boy in
nanoseconds it's not the kind of stock
that you can own and sleep well if
you're a small investor and I think by
the way that's true of all internet
stocks the advantage that Amazon had was
they had built this war chest so to
speak on their their balance sheet of
cash to to fund them through all this
Jeff Bezos made a lot of large bets and
not all of them paid off the company
didn't profit for many years in the
beginning the reason Jeff Bezos got away
with that and benefited long-terms
because he was always very direct with
employees and stakeholders in the
company
at long last by January 2002 those bets
began to pay off Amazon stock price
rebounded and Bezos company did
something it hadn't done in seven years
posted a profit the best thing can say
about him is that he was unwavering in
his confidence he could see the bigger
picture and he knew that the skeptics
were short-term errs they were not
seeing the big picture and he stuck to
the vision once the bubble burst the
investors patience for companies saying
we're going to make big investments in
building out a dot-com site to our
business was very very thin and so
Amazon took advantage of that and
started partnering with Target and Toys
R Us and the gap and other traditional
retailers the dot-com retail giant
joined forces with more than four
hundred companies but not all retailers
were willing partners I do know of a
number of cases in which he has acquired
companies in order to take out
competitors potential future competitors
rather than because he actually wants
that business to continue with his
company back on track
Bezos switched gears and increased his
focus on a much different passion on
March 6th 2003 he charted a helicopter
to scout property in a remote region of
Southwest Texas he was looking to buy up
ranches for a venture he had started in
2000 called Blue Origin Blue Origin is a
technology company whose purpose was to
develop vertical takeoff and vertical
landing rockets for human space travel
the trip was nearly a disaster shortly
after takeoff the helicopter flipped and
landed in a riverbed
in 2003 Jeff Bezos almost died in a
helicopter crash it's sort of a pattern
where he can go through something
difficult like a dot-com crash be
philosophical about it laughing off with
his big famous laughs unlike Space
Exploration ventures bankrolled by
private backers including Elon Musk
Richard Branson and John Carmack
Bezos is obsessive about keeping his
efforts at Blue Origin secret for a
variety of reasons it's pretty secretive
and I think actually from the point of
view of the space industry that's sort
of a pity what makes a good market is
when you have a bunch of competitors
openly competing and they try and
position themselves against one another
and the markets visible they compete for
money they compete for people and so
forth after six years of working behind
closed doors and locked gates blue
origins odd-looking tests rocket blasted
off
Bezos was also set to launch on another
revolutionary effort this one closer to
home this is an opportunity to hugely
expand the book industry expand pricing
expend the definition of what a book
could be but it required someone with
sufficient clout to do that end-to-end
hardware software web integration and
only Amazon was in a position to do that
on November 19 2007 Jeff Bezos took to
the Charlie Rose show to announce the
release of a groundbreaking new product
here in my hands is what we're talking
about it is called the Tyndall tell me
when you first had the idea that this
might be possible what we realized at
the time was that there were a few
technologies that were sort of
converging that we could combine
together at the right recipe and make
something that would be what we hoped
would be transformative in the world of
electronic reading the Kindle was an
instant hit Amazon put this device out
there that takes away so many of the
aesthetic pleasures that people take in
books you know you can't smell the pages
anymore dog-ear the books but it turns
out book lovers who are all these people
that feared and load this thing now they
love the Kindle the $399 ereader sold
out nationwide in just five and a half
hours the number of Kindles sold however
remains a closely guarded secret a
company spokesman said that they choose
not to disclose the number Jane Freedman
is former CEO of HarperCollins and
co-founder of open-road
integrated media no one today knows how
many Kindles there really are out there
it's a guessing game we know that there
are millions but how many millions but
its strategic for Amazon obviously
because that's what they do they keep a
lot of information close to the vest but
publishers saw the Kindle as an industry
killer there will be real blood on the
tracks of publishing in the next few
years because publishers did not wake up
soon enough to the fact that Amazon was
a competitor
while the Kindle was making serious
waves in the e-book marketplace Amazon
was preparing to make its largest
corporate acquisition to date Tony Hsieh
is CEO of Zappos calm America's leading
online shoe retailer when I first met
Jeff Bezos in 2004 he hadn't contacted
us and said they were interested in
possibly acquiring Zappos at the time we
said we weren't interested because
sapless would kind of lose its identity
Shay was hesitant to sell to Amazon they
contacted us again and said they were
willing to consider a different scenario
where we could remain independent and we
started realizing while they might
actually be really great partners Amazon
purchased the hot online shoe retailer
in the summer of 2009
Zappos investors received 10 million
Amazon shares worth about 1.2 billion
dollars at the time the deal closed I
got stopped which at this point is
better than cash and what this kind of
shows that Jeff Bezos and Amazon is
someone who yes he can steamroll the
competition when he needs to but he's
also willing to play ball and negotiate
and get what he wants
but make everybody wealthier in the
process the shoe fit but his cash cow
the Kindle was about to get some very
serious competition from a tech giant
and we call it the iPad On January 27th
2010 Apple launched the iPad also
designed for use as an electronic
reading device Bezos responded
aggressively by cutting costs and adding
new features to his ereader one thing
that Bezos has always been comfortable
doing running Amazon is playing with
very tight margins so when you see the
Kindle lowering in price what you're
seeing is Bezos recognizing what the
real long term gain here for Amazon is
to be the place where everyone buys all
of their ebooks and the Kindle is just
how they get them
the phenomenal growth of the e-book
market devastated bricks and mortar
stores Amazon came on the scene and
became a competitor to the bricks and
mortar retailers and they were the
e-tailer everybody was coexisting in
fact borders and it may have been their
downfall but borders did all of their
digital their digital selling through
Amazon had borders established its own
presence it might have been a very
different situation today according to
the author's guild Amazon had been
buying books from publishers at twelve
to thirteen dollars wholesale and
selling them as Kindle books for $9.99
taking a loss each time best-selling
author John Grisham railed against
Amazon's pricing model we're gonna get
to a point if a book is worth ten
dollars okay whether it's a discount
hardback at Amazon or an e-book sold by
Amazon for the Kindle if we're ten
dollars okay then suddenly the whole
industry is going to change you can lose
publishers you lose bookstores others
saw opportunity you look at all of the
authors that have been and empowered by
Kendall to develop a direct consumer
relationship that they never had before
and I think that's where Amazon is able
to come out a winner and all of this by
building this bridge between authors and
their readers that in the past has never
really existed Borders Books filed for
bankruptcy and Barnes and Noble the
world's largest bookshop chain is
looking for a buyer in 2011 amazon.com
stepped beyond the retail sales market
and into the video streaming ring going
head-to-head with Netflix
Andrew wallenstein is a TV editor for
Variety magazine I think if your Netflix
you're looking at Amazon and really
sizing them up as a competitor Amazon
has a lot of traction online they've got
deep pockets to buy just as much content
there at the very beginning of this kind
of effort but in time Amazon could grow
to be just as big as Netflix the
e-commerce retail giant is also fending
off growing efforts to put an end to its
untaxed online sales new laws may force
Amazon to charge local
sales tax but Bezos remains cool under
fire and unfazed
he continues to forge ahead Jeff Bezos
has his fingers and everybody's pie
he's got video streaming which competes
with Netflix he's doing music now which
competes with Apple and iTunes
he's even selling Android apps in an
amazon.com App Store that goes right
after Google's marketplace if he sees
something where Amazon can make a little
piece of money and help its margins
return you know so thin he'll go for it
going forward has gotten him this far
his space project is going even farther
in April 2011 NASA awarded Blue Origin
22 million dollars to continue
developing its space vehicle design he
was listed by Forbes as the 30th richest
person in the world estimating his net
worth at 18 point 1 billion dollars
amazon.com remains the world's largest
online retailer he's not just a
visionary with visions he's an architect
with blueprints and some notion of how
to make things work he thinks very
carefully about design and structure and
operations and that's what turns a
vision arian is somebody who actually
accomplishes something he could have
sold Amazon to Barnes & Noble or
probably to some other booksellers and
walked away with many millions of
dollars like in his early 30s since then
he just keeps on coming up with really
good ideas he's not the hard-charging
going to take no prisoners type CEO he's
somebody that has his vision for how he
wants to build this company and is able
to surround himself by people that buy
into that I think ultimately that's one
of the reasons that he's been as
successful as he has